A bunch of shows are returning with new batches
of episodes - and of course, there's also
the usual eclectic selection of movies and
licensed TV series to help take your mind
off the late summer heat.
Let's dig in to every notable new Netflix
viewing choice coming your way in August.
Otherhood will come with a little extra baggage
when it drops August 2, but don't hold that
against it.
One of its stars, Felicity Huffman, is one
of the celebrities caught up in the college
admissions scandal that's been headline news
lately.
It's safe to say that Netflix is probably
hoping said scandal won't be at the forefront
of your mind when see the cast list.
Otherhood stars Huffman, Angela Bassett, and
Patricia Arquette as a trio of moms who decide
to take a road trip to the Big Apple to reconnect
with their adult sons, making important discoveries
about their families, their friends, and themselves
along the way.
The presence of the always-excellent Bassett
alone is enough to get our attention, and
the movie marks the directorial debut of Cindy
Chupack, who has worked as a writer and producer
on TV series including Modern Family and Sex
and the City.
The trailer promises a funny, heartfelt, and
moving little film that deserves a watch,
even if one of its stars isn't doing so hot
on the PR front this year.
Dear White People has been a hilarious, thought-provoking
delight for its first two seasons, and for
the third, debuting August 2, things are about
to get real.
The series is a look at race relations from
the point of view of a group of black students
at a prestigious, mostly white fictional university.
It stars Logan Browning as Sam, the host of
the titular radio show; DeRon Horton as Lionel,
an aspiring journalist who has extra hurdles
to surmount as a gay man; and Antoinette Robertson
as Coco, a social butterfly attempting to
fit in to her lily-white environment.
Previous seasons have focused on Sam and Lionel's
efforts to discover the identity of the mysterious
leader of Order X, a shadowy secret society
- and at the conclusion of season 2, it was
revealed to be the series' narrator, Giancarlo
Esposito.
"I see you've been watching closely."
Esposito figures pretty heavily in the trailer
for season 3, so we can expect to learn more
about Order X along with Sam and Lionel.
No Good Nick is among the weirdest sitcoms
on television, and we mean that in the best
way possible.
Part 1 of the show's first season introduced
us to the oh-so average Thompson family: dad
Ed, mom Liz, son Jeremy, and daughter Molly,
who discover that they have a previously unknown,
distant relative: young Nick, whom they welcome
into their lives.
But all is not as it seems: Nick is a budding
con artist, and in addition to putting over
a long con on the Thompsons, she's also playing
her foster parents in the service of a scheme
cooked up by her imprisoned father Tony.
Part 1 was equal parts hilarity, intrigue,
and suspense, and Part 2 promises to thicken
the plot even further when it debuts August
5.
It's been a long wait for the third season
of GLOW, but the recently released trailer
for season 3 promises that it'll be worth
it when the season finally hits August 9.
The new batch of episodes sees the action
move to Las Vegas, as the Gorgeous Ladies
of Wrestling take their act to the Fan-Tan
hotel and casino under the watchful eye of
an entertainment director played by Geena
Davis.
"Viva Las Vegas."
Season 2 left plenty of plot threads to be
picked up, and star Alison Brie has teased
that the new outing will feature a deepening
of the friendship between her character Ruth
"Zoya the Destroya" Wilder and Debbie "Liberty
Belle" Eagan.
The show's deft blend of comedy with thoughtful
explorations of unconventional relationships
has always been at the center of its appeal,
and the new season looks to give its fans
the most hilarious, heartfelt outing yet.
Dexter's Michael C. Hall returns to the small
screen August 9 in the original feature In
the Shadow of the Moon, and he's just one
welcome component of the thriller's amazing
cast.
Leading the film is Boyd Holbrook, who portrays
a Philadelphia police detective on the trail
of a serial killer whose crimes seem to defy
any logical explanation; Hall will appear
as a fellow detective who is also the brother-in-law
of Holbrook's character.
The film is directed by Jim Mickle, who turned
in an amazingly atmospheric thriller in 2013's
We Are What We Are.
Additional plot details are sparse, but something
tells us that's for the best, as this sounds
like a thriller best watched going in cold.
The story of every '90s kid's favorite anxiety-ridden
wallaby continues with the feature Rocko's
Modern Life: Static Cling.
The animated movie is going meta for its return:
Rocko and friends Heffer, Filburt and Spunky
have been lost in space since the Nickelodeon
series' conclusion in 1996, and they're going
to have a few problems adjusting to our radically
different modern world.
Rocko, however, believes that this new society
can be redeemed through the power of nostalgia.
See how our heroes react to smartphones, food
trucks, and superhero movies when Rocko's
Modern Life: Static Cling drops on August
9.
"The 21st Century is a very dangerous century."
Invader Zim was one of the most insane offerings
ever fielded by Nickelodeon, and it amassed
a sizable fan base during its run from 2001
to 2006.
The animated series centered on Zim, an alien
from the planet Irk, and his attempts to conquer
Earth with the aid of his not-so-reliable
robot assistant GIR; opposing them is Dib,
a pint-sized paranormal investigator.
Despite its relatively short run, the show
has remained popular, spawning its own fan
convention, a comic book series, and a plethora
of merchandise.
Leave it to Netflix, then, to give fans a
feature film Invader Zim: Enter the Florpus!,
debuting August 16.
Most of the original cast will return to reprise
their roles, including Richard Horvitz as
Zim, Rikki Simons as GIR, and Andy Berman
as Dib; series creator Jhonen Vasquez also
returned to co-script the project.
Fans of the true crime drama series Mindhunter
have been waiting with bated breath for the
second season since the first arrived in 2017.
On August 16, they'll finally get to see the
continuing story of FBI agents Holden Ford
and Bill Tench, who forged new methods of
capturing serial killers in the '70s.
The pair are the first to interview such criminals
while in captivity to find out what makes
them tick, and the 1977-set first season saw
them cross paths with a number of real-life
monsters including the notorious "Co-Ed Killer"
Ed Kemper.
Season 2 will take place after a bit of a
time jump, focusing on a rash of killings
in Atlanta which took place between 1979 and
1981.
In what is sure to be a highlight of the new
batch of episodes, Ford and Tench will have
occasion to interview infamous "family" leader
Charles Manson.
If you've missed the comedy stylings of Marlon
Wayans, then Netflix has a movie just for
you.
Sextuplets focuses on Alan, an adoptee who
hits the road in search of his birth mother,
only to discover that he was born a sextuplet,
and that he has five identical brothers.
All of the brothers, of course, are played
by Wayans.
The movie reunites Wayans with Bresha Webb,
the co-star of his short-lived sitcom Marlon,
and the film is directed by longtime Wayans
collaborator Michael Tiddes, who directed
A Haunted House and its sequel.
Wayans is a man who knows what his audience
wants, and if you're a fan, you won't need
us to tell you to set aside August 16 to check
out Sextuplets.
Here's a little item that's been nearly four
decades in the making.
The Dark Crystal: Age of Resistance is a series
serving as a prequel to Jim Henson's 1982
fantasy feature The Dark Crystal.
The movie used pioneering puppet work to tell
the tale of a struggle to find a balance between
light and dark on the mysterious planet of
Thra.
Age of Resistance will follow the journey
of three Gelflings, voiced by Taron Egerton,
Anya Taylor-Joy, and Nathalie Emmanuel, as
they set out to discover the secret behind
the power of the evil Skeksis.
The series blends the original's signature
puppetry with lovingly rendered CGI, and its
stellar voice cast includes nearly too much
talent to list.
Even those unfamiliar with Henson's classic
film will want to get in on this one.
As in July, the new action offerings are few
in August.
Fortunately, they're all well worth checking
out; many consider Quentin Tarantino's Jackie
Brown to be among his finest works.
If you're more in the "mind-bending head trip"
mood, there's the Wachowskis' Jupiter Ascending,
a blast of pure, unadulterated sci-fi/action
craziness featuring Mila Kunis and Channing
Tatum.
There's also 2004's The Punisher, featuring
Thomas Jane in his first go-round as the legendary
Marvel anti-hero, the well-received Jason
Statham actioner The Bank Job, and Boyka:
Undisputed, the fourth film in the bone-crushing
martial arts series.
When it comes to horror, the August pickings
are, unfortunately, even slimmer.
Only two new releases will show up during
the month: the ultra-crazy Daniel Radcliffe-led
Horns, and Panic Room, David Fincher's claustrophobic
thriller starring Jodie Foster as a woman
trapped in her own home.
Sylvestor Stallone is the main attraction
among the August drama offerings, as the first
five films in the Rocky series will be available
for streaming on the first of the month.
The 1994 classic Four Weddings and a Funeral
is also on tap, as well as the 1995 coming
of age drama Now and Then and the 1998 Frankie
Lymon biography Why Do Fools Fall in Love.
On the 20th, check out one of the great Daniel
Day-Lewis performances as the ruthless gang
leader "Bill the Butcher" in Martin Scorsese's
Gangs of New York.
The new comedy offerings for August are graced
by one classic standout: Groundhog Day, which
stars Bill Murray as a man forced to relive
the same day over and over again until he
gets it right.
You can also catch Ice Cube's Are We Done
Yet?, the Sex and the City movie, the Jack
Nicholson/Diane Keaton vehicle Something's
Gotta Give, and the hilarious Anna Faris starring
in The House Bunny.
And if none of these are quite weird enough
for you, there's To Wong Foo, Thanks for Everything!
Julie Newmar, which features Wesley Snipes,
John Leguizamo, and Patrick Swayze as three
drag queens who embark on the most bizarre
road trip ever.
Aside from the ones already listed, new TV
seasons are a bit few and far between in August.
The second season of riveting crime series
The Sinner, focusing on the brutal crimes
committed by a young boy, comes to Netflix
in August.
The CW's Jane the Virgin will see its fifth
season added to the service, and the second
season of the History Channel's 14th century
drama Knightfall will also be available.
Finally, season 6 of the CW's sci-fi drama
The 100 will join the lineup on August 14.
Original comedy offerings kick off with Volume
4 of Patriot Act with Hasan Minhaj, in which
the comedian uses sly humor to deliver biting
social commentary on the state of the U.S.
in today's divisive political climate.
Also appearing are solo sets from veteran
standup Sebastian Maniscalco and director/comedian
Simon Amstell.
Finally, Tiffany Haddish Presents: They Ready,
will put the spotlight on six budding comedians
performing half-hour sets.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.